trouver dans une manifestation pro
ukrainienne Berlin affiche donc son
soutien à Kiev aujourd'hui
oui Berlin affiche
solidarité avec l'Ukraine le palais
présidentiel mais aussi le parlement
allemand le bundeslak donc qui c'est le
drapeau
ukrainien une cérémonie s'est tenue au
Palais présidentiel dans la matinée avec
les plus représentants de l'État
allemand et de nombreuses manifestations
vont rythmer toute l'après-midi dans la
capitale allemande tôt ce matin déjà des
activistes ont déposé le char que vous
pouvez certainement apercevoir derrière
moi devant l'ambassade de Russie à
Berlin un chat russe détruit sur le
champ de bataille en Ukraine en signe de
protestation contre cette guerre
déclenchée par Vladimir Poutine une
centaine de manifestants sont déjà sur
place mais ils l'ont Satan a une très
grande mobilisation ici enfin
d'après-midi notez également que le
week-end sera marqué également par
d'autres manifestations des
manifestations dites pacifistes cette
fois et notamment cette manifestation à
l'appel d'intellectuel d'artistes et de
responsables le politique qui doit se
tenir demain et qui appelle à l'arrêt
des livraisons d'armes à l'Ukraine et à
des pour parler de paix une
manifestation d'ores et déjà très
critiquée ici en Allemagne d'autant que
ces organisateurs ne se sont pas
vraiment distanciers des militants
d'extrême droite pour Poutine qui
devront qui devrait donc venir gonfler
les rangs de cette manifestation demain
Anne le chancelier Poutine à toutes les
cartes en main il peut mettre fin à
cette guerre quelle est la stratégie
allemande vis-à-vis du chef du Kremlin
on rappelle que cette guerre en Ukraine
a vu l'Allemagne opérer un vivasis
historique en matière de défense en
matière énergétique également
alors la chose ne dit pas clairement que
l'Ukraine doit gagner cette guerre mais
il dit que la Russie ne peut pas la
gagner et que Vladimir Poutine je cite
le chancelier allemand doit reconnaître
qu'il ne pourra pas atteindre les
objectifs impérialistes qu'il s'est fixé
et que c'est donc à lui de baisser les
armes concrètement cela signifie aussi
que l'Allemagne va continuer à soutenir
l'Ukraine avec des aides financières
humanitaires avec des armes également
sur ce point l'Allemagne a fait un très
long chemin en un an le 22 février le 24
février pardon 2022 a vraiment marqué
une césure dans ce pays l'Allemagne a
réinvesti dans son armée en rupture avec
sa tradition pacifice elle fournit des
armes de plus en plus lourdes à
l'Ukraine et ce malgré de fortes
inquiétudes au sein de la population et
donc le chancelier au live Scholl c'est
force aussi régulièrement de rassurer
les Allemands en rappelant son mantra et
des l'Ukraine oui mais tout faire
également pour que cette guerre ne se
transforme pas ne se transforme pas en
une guerre entre la Russie et l'Otan
merci beaucoup Anne Anne-Marie en direct
de Berlin pour France